[Musique]
toutes les cellules de mon corps sont
heureuses toutes les cellules mon gars
en scène tout est celle de mon corps
sont heureux que tu aies cellule mon
gars en scène je suis si reconnaissant
que mais c'est lui le soit heureuse et
sem je suis si reconnaissant que les sel
soit heureux l'essonne ça vous arrive
vous aussi de chanter pour remercier la
vie quand vous êtes heureux ou quand
vous avez une énorme boule de stress
dans le ventre bah c'est parfait parce
que nous aussi
moi c'est manon moi c'est frédéric ou
frais pour les intimes comme vous et on
va commencer par vous poser deux petites
questions deux petites questions
la première combien d'entre vous ont
bien conscience que le monde ne tourne
plus rond et que si on continue sur ce
même chemin on va droit dans le mur voix
des mains des mains et quelques mains
pas veulent pas manquer merci deuxième
question combien d'entre vous serez prêt
à transformer leurs habitudes à changer
leurs habitudes s'ils découvraient
l'existence d'un outil simple et
puissant qui permettrait ben d'éviter la
catastrophe
hu bin c'est parfait sachez que vous
êtes au bon endroit
car cet outil on l'a trouvé et vous
verrez il est à la portée de tout le
monde et il a un pouvoir de
transformation énorme aussi bien sur
nous-mêmes mais sur la planète toute
entière
ok vous pourriez vous dira c'est un peu
utopique talent on se serait dit la même
chose mais grâce à notre folle aventure
aux quatre coins du monde
cet outil on l'a découvert on l'a testé
et vraiment il fonctionne mon lara gut
allez c'est parti
entre maintenant et moi tout est parti
super vite on se rend compte en mars
2010 est lors d'une conférence de pierre
rabhi une de ses figures de l'écologie
du monde actuel où il invite chacun
d'entre nous à faire sa part de colibri
pour contribuer à un monde meilleur
et trois heures après on s'embrasse on
est en couple trois semaines plus tard
on décide de se lancer ensemble pour
justement faire notre part de colibris
et trois mois plus tard la prend forme
d'une association du nom de chréa titude
qui a pour objectif de contribuer à
l'éveil des consciences écologiques des
enfants et des parents
mais nos questions dans le monde du
business on n'y connaissait pas
grand-chose à l'écologie l'éducation
ah oui oui c'est vrai donc on s'est dit
quoi de mieux que d'aller nous ouvrir
l'esprit sur tous ces sujets bien voyage
d'un an sur 4 continents dans 14 pays
afin de découvrir les initiatives
écologiques et de les mettre en avance
sur les réseaux sociaux
alors c'est parti on est en septembre
2017 et on prend notre envol depuis
l'île maurice le pays où j'ai eu la
chance de grandir
hélas les projets s'enchaînent on plante
des arbres et green pop en afrique du
sud on se plonge au sein de l'école
reconnu comme l'école la plus verte au
monde
la green school de bali en indonésie ou
à une plus petite échelle on rencontre
ce couple d'indiens dans le kerala qui
met toute son énergie pour développer
une école alternative du nom de boomi
afin de reconnecter les enfants à la
nature
on rencontre aussi des ong telles que
animals asia au vietnam qui allaient
près d'engager pour mettre fin au
commerce barbare de la bile d'ours
oui de la bile d'ours et tu te souviens
quoi quand on était au fin fond du
désert d'atacama au chili
exactement au chili on trouvait pas de
projets écologiques et la merci le
marchand de glaces et nous avoir fait
rencontrer car la vraie car voilà cette
jeune entrepreneuse qui a réussi à
sortir de la cocaïne avec une thérapie
très particulière
elle ramasse les sacs déchets les sacs
plastiques qu'elle trouve dans la nature
et les coûts et à les transforme en
magnifique sac à main ouais elle est
tellement inspirante
ouais on peut le dire on a vécu des
moments fabuleux que ce soit ensemble
entre new way mais aussi avec tous les
porteurs de projets que l'on a
rencontrés sans parler de la nature
autour de nous qui était qui était si
splendides
encore merci la vie pour tout ce que tu
nous offres et on continue d'avancer
comme cela en surfant sur cette vague
d'émerveillement qui ne cesse de grandir
et au fur et à mesure de nos découvertes
notre conscience s'élargit et à
s'élargit tellement qu'on al'impression
de
s'y perdre ouais en plus de faire des
marches de ramassage de déchets de faire
des plaintes et des plantations d'arbres
on se retrouve à pratiquer le yoga la
cuisine vivante ou encore la méditation
alors vous imaginez bien nous tout petit
aventurier que nous sommes face à cet
immense diversité de projets qui se
disent tous contribuer à un monde
meilleur et bien on va dire qu'il ya à
peu près mille et une questions assez
profonde qui nous ont turbiné 1 je
dirais exactement maintenant ils ont
turlupiner les questions comme qu'est ce
que justement cette cette conscience
écologique ou jusqu'où s'étend
l'écologie jusqu'au simple respect de la
planète tout c'est aussi le respect de
soi et de l'humain dans sa globalité
vous demande aussi au cas où un ace
qu'il existerait un outil qui serait
simple puissant et qui pourrait nous
aider à contribuer à ce monde plus juste
et plus durable que nous souhaitons et
vous savez quoi
on a trouvé une partie de ses réponses
et on va vous en partager quelques-unes
alors déjà pour nous la conscience
écologique
elle se définit comme être profondément
en lien avec nous mêmes avec les autres
et avec la nature avec le vivant en fait
c'est ça avec le vivant et canton
recréer ce lien avec le vivant et bien
ça paraît logique de vouloir le
respecter parce que le vivant c'est nous
et ainsi contribuer à un monde plus
juste et plus durable
ça tient la route son truc ouais je
pense bien et donc concrètement comment
on fait concrètement c'est là où
intervient cet outil qu'on vous parlait
tout à l'heure un outil simple puissant
qui permet de recréer ce lien
et oui cet outil on l'a découvert après
six mois de voyage il nous est comme
tombé dessus et pas n'importe où au
costa rica
vous voyez ce pays magnifique avec des
paysages grandioses des crocodiles des
iguanes des perroquets multicolores les
habitants chaleureux qui incarne
pleinement leurs devis
la poule à villa on ressent leur
authenticité et leur générosité le lien
étroit qu'ils ont avec la nature
l'harmonie le bonheur l'amour oui bon la
poule habile à quoi la poule à vide à
quoi et c'est dans une communauté en
particulier petite communauté du nom de
finca mort faut que l'on se retrouve à
passer un séjour d'une semaine très
particulier entouré de personnes qui
disent merci
oui oui merci tout le temps tout le
temps mais vraiment tout le temps
lors des séances de yoga le matin
pendant les cérémonies chamanique le
soir en regardant le lever du soleil
avant de passer à table et j'ai envie de
dire limite même à chaque bouchée voyez
alors c'est quoi ce mot qui disent tout
le temps qu'ils commencent par mer et
qui finit par si on n'entend pas c'est
quoi
oui exactement ils disent tous tout le
temps merci et au début maintenant et
moi on comprenait pas pourquoi autant de
mercy puis on a commencé à saupoudrer
ses petits merci ici et là dans nos
actions quotidiennes et on a eu comme un
déclic un déclic
la gratitude cet outil qui peut paraître
si banal qui est si simple à utiliser
peut avoir un impact énorme sur sur toi
sur moi sur vous sur le tout quoi robert
et month chercheurs experts
scientifiques américains des mondes
depuis plus de 20 ans tous les bénéfices
de la gratitude qui soit sur le plan
physique émotionnel relationnelles ou
encore spirituel mais cet outil est
tellement victime de sa facilité
d'utilisation mais aussi de tous nos
conditionnements que ben en fait
on l'oubli ouais par habitude on se
focalise davantage sur ce qui nous
manque
plutôt que de se réjouir de tout ce que
l'on a déjà et si maintenant ensemble
nous partions en voyage afin de changer
notre perception du monde
allez on va vivre une petite expérience
ensemble on veut aller à la recherche
des cadeaux de la vie
car comme le dit notre ami robert
lorsque je suis dans la gratitude je
comprends que rien dans la vie nommé du
et que tous ceux qui m'entourent est un
cadeau à une question pour vous merci
robert
bah ouais mais une question pour qu'est
ce qui vous rend heureux car savoir ce
que vous aimez ce qui vous fait plaisir
ce qui vous fait vibrer est un excellent
moyen d'approcher la gratitude
allez pour vous aider ça peut être
peut-être que vous aimez faire une
balade à vélo le long du port
ou alors faire un dîner entre amis ou
encore manger une bonne glace au
chocolat sur la plage en fin d'après
midi
ouais encore mieux voilà ça va est ce
que vous voyez est ce que vous avez tous
une chose en tête qui vous fait plaisir
c'est bon ben je pas sur la est-ce que
vous avez tout une chose en tête qui
vous fait plaisir
ok oui donc maintenant vous avez cette
chose en tête
pensez à ce pour quoi vous pourriez être
reconnaissant alors si on reprend un
exemple de faire une balade à vélo le
long du port ça pourrait être être
reconnaissant de votre corps qui vous
permet de faire cet exercice
ou alors pour la simple odeur de la mer
que vous respirez
si on prend l'exemple du repas entre
amis vous pourriez être reconnaissants
pour leur présence ou pour leur
complicité est la bonne glace alors et
si vous adorez manger une bonne glace au
chocolat sur la plage en fin d'après
midi jeudi il ya même une marie bong la
fin comme on dit dans ton pays
voilà une marine glace
vous pourriez remercier toutes les
personnes qui ont contribué à ce que
cette glace soit en ce moment man dans
votre main ou pour le soleil qui se
couche au loin ça va vous avez compris
le principe mais combien lucratif
auj prenez quelques instants pour
intégrer la gratitude à votre exemple
profiter pleinement de ce moment
ressentez cette énergie de gratitude qui
circulent en vous mêmes
circulent dans toutes vos cellules on
peut voir qu'il ya quelques petits
sourires la capelle sur vos visages
moi je vois même les personnes qui ont
des petits fristot est normal moi aussi
en fait donc comme on vient
d'expérimenter en quelques secondes la
ensemble on peut voir que la gratitude
est un outil qui peut avoir un impact
énorme et qui peut nous permettre de
nous reconnecter facilement aux vivants
au tout bah oui de toute façon on sait
que tout est lié toute énergie tout et
vibrations et comme chaque action
entraîne une réaction quand on dit merci
et bien on en est mais une oliveraie
dans l'univers que tout bâtiment leur
revenir vers nous on va garder ça pour
le prochain tu as dit ok alors en
redescendant sur terre ce que manon
essayer de vous expliquer c'est que si
on arrive à changer notre perception
grâce à la gratitude
on peut vraiment éviter la catastrophe
et ensemble contribuer à un monde
meilleur
ouais pas mal c'est d'accord et si on a
juste une chose mais une chose à retenir
de notre voyage d'un an lors duquel nous
avons vu une centaine de projets
écologiques c'est bien l'importance de
cultiver cet esprit de gratitude que ce
soit pour notre propre bien-être mais
aussi pour pouvoir transmettre cette
force aux enfants qui sont les citoyens
de demain afin qu'ils puissent vivre
dans un monde plus
sts et fut durable et vous qu'est ce que
vous avez envie de faire pour demain
peut-être que vous auriez envie de nous
accompagner sur ce chemin de la
gratitude
les auberges gîtes et dire merci sont
tellement infinie je peux dire merci à
mes petites cellules qui sont en bonne
santé
ouais moi je peux dire merci à ma voix
qui me permet de partager ce message
avec vous je peux dire merci à toi de
m'accompagner dans la vie je veux dire
merci à la lumière qui nous éblouit peut
dire merci à la régie aux organisateurs
au coach qui nous ont si bien accompagné
et on peut dire merci à abou dhabi les
mêmes séries
que les deux montants de toutes les
cellules de remparts sont saines tout
l'excellent le mans caen chanteuse
toutes les cellules de mon enfance et je
suis sûr reconnaissant que metz est
heureuse et celle encore je suis si
reconnaissant que même cellule soit
heureux des cinq toutes les cellules de
peau comme saute
je
[Applaudissements]